so Cameron why are we here I'm just
checking out this soccer I mean football
scores and how does that relate to
JavaScript yeah you'll see okay so if I
ask you whether or not the u.s. won any
of these games how would you respond
let's start with this first one against
Ghana did we win
true correct okay what about this one
against Belgium false also correct all
right one last one what about that one
against Argentina hmm we didn't even
play them ah correct and JavaScript
gives us a way of expressing this is
undefined okay I see what you're getting
at true and false isn't as cut and dry
as our football chart javascript has a
set of values that can evaluate to true
or false but may not equal true or false
because of this we call these values
truthy and falsy
under truthy we've got true nonzero
numbers strings with a length of at
least one objects arrays and functions
and under fall see we've got false 0
empty strings undefined null and not a
number undefined means that the variable
doesn't exist in the interpreter doesn't
know what you're referring to null means
that the variable exists but has well no
value it's usually used as a placeholder
and not a number is not a number or a
result that isn't a number there's a
link in the instructors notes comparing
truthy and falsy values in python and
javascript let's take a quiz to make
sure you've got them all